por primera vez de la historia los
mexicanos votarán sobre si su presidente
debe terminar su mandato anticipadamente
este inédito referéndum ha sido
promovido por el propio andrés manuel
lópez obrador como respuesta a las voces
críticas de su sección cómo está listo
para que el próximo 10 de abril acudan a
votar todas las personas interesadas en
participar en este proceso las 92
millones 823 mil 216 ciudadanas y
ciudadanos inscritos en la lista nominal
de electores tendrán una papeleta
esperándoles en la casilla que les
corresponde los partidos de oposición
han llamado al boicot de la votación en
señalado que lópez obrador busca
extender su mandato pese a que ha
expresado que no buscará la reelección
para el 2024 que el presidente va a
seguir
más los que queremos de esta reforma
esté bien para todos para mí es una
marcha en la que se refleja nuestra
nuestro descontento a lo que está
pasando es el ide es la manera que se
hizo lograr la ratificación que la
convirtieron una publicidad para favor
del jugador genera por el mismo andrés
manuel lópez obrador mantiene un índice
de aprobación del casi el 60 por ciento
el presidente del órgano electoral
resaltó que se conocerán los resultados
de la misma noche del domingo lópez
obrador ha impulsado varias consultas
ciudadanas a lo largo de su mandato que
inició en el 2018 como la consulta sobre
la construcción del tren maya que contó
con menos del 1% de participación de los
electores de mexico también hubo uno
sobre la cancelación de un aeropuerto
casi terminado para la ciudad de mexico
fue una consulta de opinión no
vinculante y no regulado por la ley
federal el más reciente por el 2021
sobre la posibilidad de enjuiciar a ex
mandatarios por corrupción participaron
el 7 por ciento de los mexicanos
habilitados para votar